[Музика]
добре, хлопці, я радий вас знову бачити, і
сьогодні ми почали говорити про нову
тему, ми почали говорити про
Великобританію, тому познайомтеся з Великобританією, і це чудово,
давайте почнемо, тому, коли ми говоримо про
Великобританію, нам потрібно  знайте про
Британські острови, тому коли вам це спадає на
думку, і ви думаєте, що Великобританія
Великобританія є більшим островом, ви можете побачити
його зеленим, і він складається з Англії,
Шотландії та трьох країн Уельсу, тоді
ви можете почути назву Сполучене Королівство Сполучене Королівство
Королівство знову, ви можете побачити
його зеленим, складається з Англії Шотландії
Уельсу та Північної Ірландії, частини
меншого острова, який ви можете побачити на екрані,
ніж Британські острови, ви повинні знати,
що існує більше, ніж просто ці два
великі острови, їх багато  і
знову на цих островах ви знайдете
такі назви менших островів, як
Англія Шотландія Уельс Північна Ірландія
та Ірландія та всі невеликі
навколишні острови, як острів
Уайт старі коліна волосся b  Ідді
або Шетландські острови,
і всі вони повсюди навколо цих
великих островів, і ви повинні знати, що
Великобританія не має жодних сухопутних
кордонів з іншими європейськими країнами,
добре, що ви знаєте про цю країну,
я впевнений, що ви знаєте
Давайте дізнаємося
, що у вас в голові
про цю країну, тож, що є
столицею Англії, дуже легко, звичайно,
це Лондон, а потім столиця
Шотландії, а це місто Единбург, а
потім столиця Уельсу  дуже
маленька країна, і це Кардіфф, то
що є столицею Північної Ірландії,
а столицею Північної Ірландії є
Белфаст, не змішуйте це з Дубліном, тому що
Дублін є столицею Ірландії, а
Ірландія є незалежною державою, тоді
як найбільше місто  у
Великобританії відповідь очевидна,
звичайно, це Лондон, який є главою
держави у Великобританії в даний час
його королева Єлизавета друга і
яка валюта в Англії  rency
це фунт, а не євро, цікаво, тому як
люди називають прапор Великобританії, ви бачите, що їхній
прапор має назву, і
це Union Jack, добре, то можете спробувати ще
раз столиця Англії Лондон
столиця Шотландії Единбург
столиця Уельсу Кардіфф столиця
Північної Ірландії Белфаст найбільше
місто Великобританії Лондон
глава держави Королева тепер королева
Єлизавета друга і валюта
фунт і назва прапора Юніон
Джек у вас є підказка на екрані
давайте рухаємося далі я  У мене таке запитання,
яка традиція дуже популярна в
Британії, і це відбувається близько п’ятої
години, так, можливо, ви знаєте, і
це чай о п’ятій годині, але на наших уроках
ми будемо пити драматичний чай у п’яту годину,
а сьогодні  ми збираємося поговорити
про минулий простий і минулий тривалий
часи
добре, так що минулий безперервний час, як ми утворимо
цей час, нам потрібно утворити його з
формою минулого дієслова to be
it is гірше і де і формою ing
Основний дієслово  а ключові слова - це
доки і коли я наведу вам такий
приклад, коли я проходив повз
будинки парламенту,
я бачив прем'єр-міністра, це
ситуація, про яку ми сьогодні будемо говорити,
тому просте минуле буде в парі
з  минуле безперервне,
і якщо використовується разом з when then
simple past представляє цю дію на сорочці,
яка перериває довшу дію,
наприклад, я йшов, коли він кричав на
мене, буквально я йшов, коли він
кричав на мене, тому він перервав мене, коли я
ходив, друге речення, яке вона
складала  папери, коли вона спіймала свій
палець, іноді ми різали пальці
папером, і вона складала, і вона різала так,
що сорочка дія розрізалася складаючи - це
більш тривала дія вони мили машину,
коли кіт стрибнув на неї, тому вони
прали довгий процес і  кіт
стрибнув на машину добре, тоді ви також можете
мати, поки добре показує нам, що щось
відбувалося в момент розмови
він показав це мені, коли я йшов я
був у процесі, поки ш  я
складала папери, вона порізала палець, кіт
стрибнув на машину, коли вони її
мили, поки ми дивилися
фільм жахів,
подзвонили в двері, що страшно дивитися
фільм жахів і знову чути, як хтось дзвонить
добре, ви маєте зауважити, що
минуле безперервне для тривалих
дій подивіться тут дитина спала,
поки мама знову готувала
ви можете використовувати while, щоб говорити про дві тривалі
дії, що відбуваються одночасно тут
ми маємо
дві довгі дії, які вони підкреслені
, спав готував  по-друге,
мама готувала, поки дитина
спала, майже те саме речення,
але інший порядок дій, які я
їхав, поки мама розмовляла зі мною, я
керував своєю машиною, а мама
говорила зі мною
дві довгі дії в минулому, тому  ось
ми знову маємо довгі дії та
тривалі дії, давайте спробуємо і потренуємося, щоб
ви повинні заповнити минуле чи минуле
безперервне, подивіться,
коли mrs.  Галлін відчиняє двері, її
діти роблять домашнє завдання. Тут у нас є
одна коротка і одна довга дія,
яка, на вашу думку, є короткою
, тож коротка, на мою думку, це
місіс.  Гюлен відчинила двері, вона увійшла
в кімнату, і діти
робили домашнє завдання, давайте подивимося
правильну відповідь, коли пані.  Голан відкрила
двері, її діти робили
домашнє завдання добре друге, що ви
робили вчора вранці Я вчуся на іспит,
тож у нас є дві короткі або довгі
дії, у нас є дві довгі дії, про які
запитує нас людина  тривала
дія, що ми робили вчора
вранці, і знову це довгий
період часу, і ми повинні сказати, що я
готувався до іспиту, і знову, будь ласка,
пам'ятайте, що це питання, тому
потрібно зробити інверсію, що ви
робили вчора вранці  Я вчився
до іспиту, подумайте про вашу ситуацію,
що ви робили вчора вранці, добре,
можливо, ви снідали, чи, можливо,
ви дивилися уроки, чи, можливо,
ви розважалися з друзями,
тому подивіться наступне, що він прийшов на
зустріч  минулої п’ятниці, добре, у вас є
знак питання, тож ви повинні скласти
речення, а в минулу п’ятницю ми отримали так
завершену дію в минулому, тому ми думаємо
про минуле просте, і щоб скласти
запитання, нам потрібно зробити це, і ось  в
відповідь, чи прибув він на зустріч минулої
п'ятниці, будь ласка, згадайте і пам'ятайте,
що коли у вас є did, у вас є
перша форма дієслова без закінчень
okay наступна вони фарбують стіни, коли
ваша мама знову прийде додому, у нас є
питання, тому тут  і у нас є дві
дії, одна довга, а
друга коротка,
знову мама приходить, і це коротка дія,
вона просто заходить, вона просто входить до кімнати, і вони
фарбують стіни, це довга дія, а
тепер давайте заберемо цю ситуацію в
минуле, щоб ви  Я маю знак питання
, це питання, чи фарбували
стіни, коли твоя мама прийшла додому,
де ти виконуєш домашні завдання, коли
батьки прийшли до твої кімнати, де
ти вчора дивишся уроки онлайн,
коли твій друг подзвонив сюди,
де ти п'єш  якийсь кулер під час
їсти чіпси добре, так що наступний,
будь ласка,
а потім підготуйте машину, його сестра,
робота в саду, хм, зайнята, зроблено над
системою, тому тривала дія для цього зроблено,
тому що він ремонтує т  він автомобіль і
сестра або в саду, то що
тут має бути, поки Ден ремонтував машину,
його сестра працювала в саду дві
дії одночасно і тривалі дії
вони дивляться телевізор, коли гасне світло
,
дуже неприємна ситуація,
ви уявляєте, що сидите  на себе або
насолоджуватися найкращим фільмом, який ви вибрали,
і світло гасне дуже неприємно, але
давайте виправимо це, щоб вони довгий час
дивилися телевізор, коли
світло згасло,
так, це правильно, тоді номер сім
добре, мама повісила одяг своїх двох
дочки знову миють посуд зайнята
сім'я і дочки - помічники
до речі, ти любиш мити посуд я
не
так, поки мама довга дія і
дочки знову довга дія тому
відповідь - поки мама
вішала одяг їй  дві дочки
мили посуд добре, тож я сподіваюся, що
ця тема для вас цілком зрозуміла,
давайте перейдемо далі добре, хлопці,
граючи в цю гру, коли я призначив вам
пограти в неї  додому, а тепер давайте пограємо зі
мною онлайн ах у мене тут я Ольга та
Ваня 7b хто це може бути
добре так що давайте грати в кубики ой добре так минуле
просте минуле продовжується добре ой який з
них так правильний це мої
батьки ми  починаючи з того часу, коли вони познайомилися з
довгим процесом навчання і зустрілися тут,
вони хм, я зробив це правильно, добре, тому мої бали,
Ваня, добре,
тоді, поки я, історія з горами добре,
ми обидва правильні добре, так що наступне
добре мій брат
[Музика]
добре так поки  мій брат грав у
комп'ютерні ігри моя мама готувала занадто
довгі дії, які відбувалися одночасно
в минулому ладно наступний коли дзвінок
добре
[музика]
ти бачите, коли пролунав дзвінок я відкрив
двері, і я побачив, як дії мого друга
відбуваються один за одним  тобто
виконувати прості короткі дії, як у
казках або в оповіданнях, щоб їх слід
було ранжувати, відкривати та дивитися добре
The Beatles з Ліверпуля, Британія,
прикида,
так, щоб ви могли сказати, що Beatles походять з
Ліверпуля,
якщо ви маєте на увазі Джейка, як загальні знання,
але r  emember, ми граємо після простого
і минулого безперервного, тому вони прийшли з
Ліверпуля, привіт, коли вона вийшла з вікна,
вона так, ми обидва правильно відповіли,
виглянула у вікно, і вона побачила
добре мм-хм те саме речення
[Музика]
так, так я був  дивлюся телевізор, коли моя мама
поверталася додому на презентації, у нас
було добре, моя мама повернулася додому, а
діти виконували домашнє завдання,
ви пам’ятаєте майже однаковий час речення,
так, правильно для нас обох добре
[Музика]
так, так, я лежав на  тому що я зробив
це неправильно, тому що не так я збрехав,
це починалося, звичайно, це не
починалося це коротка дія, хлопці,
добре робити помилки, поки ви вивчаєте
помилки, змушуйте вас рости добре, давайте подивимося
на рахунок після моєї помилки, так, я
гуляв, і друг написав повідомлення добре,
я знову говорив довго, і мама
поставила мені запитання, коли я був дитиною, я
хотів бути співачкою,
добре, тоді приходить
[Музика]
так, що вона спить, ми повинні почати
з війни, як це  це питання а  і
телефон задзвонив, це перервало її сон
добре мм-хм вчора о 5:00 я показав,
що я роблю довгу дію, я
читав дуже цікаву книгу, я був
у процесі вчора о 5:00 знову, як
у історії, яку ми пішли  і ми купили
дії слідувати одна за одною привіт
[Музика]
знову те саме я обідав і пішов,
як в історії в минулому так, вона
не розбила скло, ви бачите, не
розбили, коли ми зробили дієслово should
go into  перша форма не зламалася, але
зламалася добре
[Музика]
так, твій комп'ютер розчавився, коли ти
виконував домашнє завдання неприємна
ситуація, добре, і чи добре ти
добре володієш англійською так, я маю на увазі, я зробив
помилку навмисне, щоб бути хорошим  в англійській мові
потрібно тренуватися, практика робить
ідеальних хлопців, тож давайте практикуватимемо разом,
а для домашнього завдання у мене є такий
виклик, це головоломка Великобританії, я
не знаю, можливо, ви робили такі головоломки
раніше, можливо, ні, тому я спробую  пояснити
вам, що вам тут робити
, можливо, є підказки  ви можете вгадати слово,
і, можливо, це слово досить очевидне,
це Велика Британія, а там ви
можете побачити цифри 1 2 3 4 Об'єднані
третя буква - це я, тож я прихований
під номером 1, тому тут я повинен помістити я
вас  тепер буква T прихована під цифрою 2, тому
тут я б поставив T, і це просто
суміш літер, які ви повинні
вклонитися, і ці підказки дадуть вам
підказку, що вам потрібно зробити, щоб
ви отримали це  буква під номером 5
Королівство знову це
I, тому знову це буде я
тут, а Королівство і О буде під
номером шести, тому завдання полягає в тому, щоб розшифрувати кожне з підказкових слів, і ви повинні скопіювати літери в пронумерованих
я
сподіваюся, що це завдання буде досить легким,
але цікавим, ви можете складати такі
завдання для своїх однокласників
, це дуже гарне тренування для вашого
мозку, тому, хлопці, я чекаю ваших
відповідей, ви знаєте мої  електронною поштою, ви можете надіслати
її на мою електронну пошту або зачекати до наступного
уроку  щоб ми отримували правильні відповіді
на екрані, тому дізнайтеся більше про
Великобританію, дивіться відео, розкажіть нам, що
ви знаєте про цю країну, і
слідкуйте за оновленнями до наступної зустрічі
[Музика]